Today I'd like to share with you three fake
proofs, in increasing order of subtlety,
and then discuss what each one of
them has to tell us about math.
The first proof is for a formula
for the surface area of a sphere,
and the way that it starts is to subdivide that
sphere into vertical slices, the way you might
chop up an orange or paint a beach ball.
We then unravel all of those wedge slices from
the northern hemisphere so that they poke up
like this, and then symmetrically unravel all
of those from the southern hemisphere below,
and now interlace those pieces to get a shape
whose area we want to figure out. The base of this
shape came from the circumference of the sphere;
it's an unraveled equator. So its length
is 2π times the radius of the sphere.
And then the other side of this shape came
from the height of one of these wedges,
which is a quarter of a walk around the sphere,
and so it has a length of π/2 times R. The
idea is that this is only an approximation,
the edges might not be perfectly straight,
but if we think of the limit as we do
finer and finer slices of the sphere,
this shape whose area we want to know
gets closer to being a perfect rectangle,
one whose area will be π/2 R times 2π R. Or
in other words, π squared times R squared.
The proof is elegant. It translates a hard problem
into a situation that's easier to understand.
It has that element of surprise while
still being intuitive. It's only fault,
really, is that it's completely wrong. The true
surface area of a sphere is 4π R squared.
I originally saw this example thanks
to Henry Reich, and to be fair,
it's not necessarily inconsistent with the 4π R
squared formula, just so long as π is equal to 4.
For the next proof I'd like to show you a simple
argument for the fact that π is equal to four.
We start off with a circle, say with radius 1, and
we ask how can we figure out its circumference.
After all π is by definition the ratio of this
circumference to the diameter of the circle. We
start off by drawing the square whose side lengths
are all tangent to that circle. It's not too hard
to see that the perimeter of the square is 8.
Then, and some of you may have seen this before
it's a kind of classic argument, the argument
proceeds by producing a sequence of curves, all
of whom also have this perimeter of 8, but which
more and more closely approximate the circle.
But the full nuance of this example is
not always emphasized. First of all,
just to make things crystal clear, the way
each of these iterations works is to fold
in each of the corners of the previous shape
so that they just barely kiss the circle.
You can take a moment to convince yourself
that in each region where a fold happened, the
perimeter doesn't change. For example in the upper
right here, instead of walking up and then left,
the new curve goes left and then up. And something
similar is true at all of the folds of all of the
different iterations, wherever the previous
iteration went direction A then direction B,
the new iteration goes direction B then
direction A. But no length is lost or gained.
Some of you might say, well obviously this isn't
going to give the true perimeter of the circle,
because no matter how many iterations you
do, when you zoom in it remains jagged.
It's not a smooth curve, you're taking these
very inefficient steps along the circle.
While that is true and ultimately the reason
things are wrong, if you want to appreciate
the lesson this example is teaching us, the
claim of the example is not that any one of
these approximations equals the curve. It's that
the limit of all of the approximations equals our
circle, and to appreciate the lesson that this
example teaches us, it's worth taking a moment to
be a little more mathematically precise about what
I mean by the limit of a sequence of curves.
Let's say we describe the very first shape,
this square, as a parametric function.
Something that has an input t,
and it outputs a point in 2d space
so that as t ranges from 0 to 1, it traces that
square. I'll call that function c0. And likewise
we can parametrize the next iteration with
a function I'll call c1. As the parameter t
ranges from zero up to one, the output of
this function traces along that curve. This
is just so that we can think of these
shapes as instead being functions.
Now i want you to consider a particular value of
t, maybe 0.2, and then consider the sequence of
points that you get by evaluating the sequence
of functions we have at this particular point.
Next I want you to consider the limit
as n approaches infinity of c_n of 0.2.
This limit is a well-defined point in 2d space,
in fact that point sits on the circle. And there's
nothing specific about 0.2, we could do this
limiting process for any input t, and so I can
define a new function that I'll call c_infinity,
which by definition at any input t is whatever
this limiting value for all the curves is.
So here's the point: That limiting function
c_infinity is the circle. It's not an
approximation of the circle, it's not some jagged
version of the circle, it is the genuine smooth
circular curve whose perimeter we want to know.
And what's also true is that the limit of the
lengths of all of our curves really is eight,
because each individual curve really does
have a perimeter of eight. And there are
all sorts of examples throughout calculus
when we talk about approximating one thing
we want to know as a limit of a bunch of
other things that are easier to understand,
so the question at the heart here is why exactly
is it not okay to do that in this example?
Maybe at this point you step back and say, you
know it's just not enough for things to look
the same. This is why we need rigor, it's why we
need proofs, it's why, since the days of Euclid,
mathematicians have followed in his footsteps and
deduced truths step-by-step from axioms forward.
But for this last example I would like to do
something that doesn't lean as hard on visual
intuition, and instead give a Euclid-style proof
for the claim that all triangles are isosceles.
The way this will work is we'll take any
particular triangle and make no assumptions about
it. I'll label its vertices A, B and C. And what
I would like to prove for you is that the side
length AB is necessarily equal to the side length
AC. Now to be clear, the result is obviously
false, just in the diagram I've drawn you can
visually see that these lengths are not equal to
each other. But I challenge you to see if you can
identify what's wrong about the proof I'm about to
show you. Honestly, it's very subtle, and three
gold stars for anyone who can identify it.
The first thing I'll do is draw the
perpendicular bisector for the line BC.
So that means this angle here is 90 degrees, and
this length is by definition the same as this
length. And we'll label that intersection point D.
And then next I will draw the angle bisector at A,
which means by definition this little angle here
is the same as this little angle here. I'll label
both of them alpha. And we'll say that the
point where these two intersect is P.
And now like, a lot of Euclid-style proofs,
we're just going to draw some new lines,
figure out what things must be equal, and get some
conclusions. For instance, let's draw the line
from P which is perpendicular to the side length
AC, and we'll label that intersection point E.
And likewise we'll draw the line from
P down to the other side length AB,
again it's perpendicular, and we'll
label that intersection point F.
My first claim is that this triangle here, which
is AFP, is the same, or at least congruent, to
this triangle over here, AEP. Essentially this
follows from symmetry across that angle bisector.
More specifically, we can say they share a side
length, and then they both have an angle alpha,
and both have an angle 90 degrees, so it follows
by the side-angle-angle congruent relation. Maybe
my drawing is a little bit sloppy, but the logic
helps us see that they do have to be the same.
Next I'll draw a line from P down to B, and then
from P down to C, and I claim that this triangle
here is congruent to its reflection across that
perpendicular bisector, which will be CPD. Again
the symmetry maybe helps make this clear, but
more rigorously they both have the same base,
they both have a 90 degree angle, and they
both have the same height, so it follows by
the side-angle-side relation. So based on that
first pair of triangles, I'm going to mark this
side length here as being the same as this side
length here, marking them with double tick marks.
And based on the second triangle
relation I'll mark this side length here
as the same as this line over here,
marking them with triple tick marks.
And so from that, we have two more
triangles that need to be the same,
namely this one over here, and the one with
corresponding two side lengths over here. And
the reasoning here is they both have that triple
ticked side, a double ticked side, and they're
both 90-degree triangles, so this follows by the
90-degree side-side-angle congruence relation.
And all of those are valid congruence relations,
I'm not pulling the wool over your eyes with one
of those. All of this will basically be enough
to show us why AB has to be the same as BC.
That first pair of triangles implies that
the length AF is the same as the length AE,
those are corresponding sides to each other.
I'll just color them in red here. And then that
last triangle relation guarantees for us that the
side FB is going to be the same as the side EC.
I'll kind of color both of those in blue.
And finally the result we want basically
comes from adding up these two equations.
The length AF plus FB is clearly the same
as the total length AB. And likewise the length
AE plus EC is the same as the total length AC.
So all-in-all, the side length AB has to be
the same as the side length AC. And because
we made no assumptions about the triangle,
this implies that any triangle is isosceles.
Actually, for that matter, since we made no
assumptions about the specific two sides we chose,
it implies that any triangle is equilateral.
So this leaves us, somewhat disturbingly,
with three different possibilities: All
triangles really are equilateral, that's
just the truth of the universe, or you can use
Euclid-style reasoning to derive false results,
or there's something wrong in the proof.
But if there is where exactly is it?
So what exactly is going on
with these three examples?
Now the thing that's a little bit troubling
about that first example with the sphere
is that it is very similar in
spirit to a lot of other famous and
supposedly true visual proofs from geometry.
For example, there's a very famous proof about
the area of a circle. It starts off by dividing it
into a bunch of little pizza wedges and you take
all those wedges and you straighten them out,
essentially lining up the crust of that pizza
and then we take half of the wedges and
inter-slice them with the other half.
And the idea is that this might not be a perfect
rectangle, it's got some bumps and curves,
but as you take thinner and thinner slices you
get something that's closer and closer to a
true rectangle. And the width of that rectangle
comes from half the circumference of the circle,
which is by definition π times r. And
then the height of that rectangle comes
from the radius of the circle r. Meaning
that the whole area is π r squared.
This time the result is valid, but why is it
not okay to do what we did with the spheres
but somehow it is okay to do
this with the pizza slices?
The main problem with the sphere argument is that
when we flatten out all of those orange wedges
if we were to do it accurately in
a way that preserves their area,
they don't look like triangles, they should
bulge outward. And if you want to see this
let's think really critically about just one
particular one of those wedges on the sphere and
ask yourself how does the width across that wedge,
this little portion of a line of latitude, vary
as you go up and down the wedge? In particular, if
you consider the angle phi from the z-axis down to
a point on this wedge, as we walk down it, what's
the length of that width as a function of phi?
For those of you curious about the
details of these sorts of things,
you'd start off by drawing this line up here from
the z-axis to our point on the wedge. Its length
will be the radius of the sphere r times the sine
of this angle. That lets us deduce how long the
total line of latitude is where we're sitting.
It'll basically be 2π times that radial line
2π r sine of phi. And then the width of the
wedge that we care about is just some constant
proportion of that full line of latitude.
Now the details don't matter too much,
the one thing I want you to notice is that this
is not a linear relationship. As you walk from
the top of that wedge down to the bottom
letting phi range from zero up to π halves,
the width of the wedge doesn't grow linearly,
instead it grows according to a sine curve.
And so when we're unwrapping all of these
wedges, if we want those widths to be preserved
they should end up a little bit chubbier around
the base; their side lengths are not linear.
What this means is when we try to interlace
all of the wedges from the northern hemisphere
with those from the southern there's a meaningful
amount of overlap between those non-linear edges.
And we can't wave our hands about a limiting
argument. This is an overlap that persists
as you take finer and finer subdivisions. And
ultimately it's that overlap that accounts for
the difference between our false answer with the
π squared from the true answer that has four π.
It reminds me of one of those rearrangement
puzzles where you have a number of pieces and just
by moving them around you can seemingly create
area out of nowhere. For example, right now I've
arranged all these pieces to form a triangle,
except it's missing two units of area in the
middle. Now I want you to focus on the vertices of
that triangle, these white dots. Those don't move,
I'm not pulling any trickery with that, but
I can rearrange all of the pieces back to how
they originally were so that those two units of
area in the middle seem to disappear, all the
constituent parts remain the same, the triangle
that they form remains the same and yet two
units of area seem to appear out of nowhere.
If you've never seen this one before by the way
I highly encourage you to pause and try to think
it through, it's a very fun little puzzle.
The answer starts to reveal itself if we
carefully draw the edges of this triangle
and zoom in close enough to see that our pieces
don't actually fit inside the triangle, they
bulge out ever so slightly. Or, at least, arranged
like this they bulge out ever so slightly. When we
rearrange them and we zoom back in we can see
that they dent inward ever so slightly and that
very subtle difference between the bulge out and
the dent inward accounts for all of the difference
in area. The slope of the edge of this blue
triangle works out to be 5 divided by 2 whereas
the slope of the edge of this red triangle works
out to be 7 divided by 3. Those numbers are close
enough to look similar as slope but they allow for
this denting inward and the bulging outward.
You have to be wary of lines that are made to
look straight when you haven't had explicit
confirmation that they actually are straight.
One quick added comment on the sphere.
The fundamental issue here is that the geometry
of a curved surface is fundamentally different
from the geometry of flat space. The relevant
search term here would be gaussian curvature.
You can't flatten things out from a sphere
without losing geometric information.
Now when you do see limiting arguments that
relate to little pieces on a sphere that
somehow get flattened out and are reasoned through
there. Those only can work if the limiting pieces
that you're talking about get smaller in both
directions. It's only when you zoom in close to
a curved surface that it appears locally flat. The
issue with our orange wedge argument is that our
pieces never got exposed to that local flatness
because they only got thin in one direction; they
maintain the curvature in that other direction.
Now on the topic of the subtlety of limiting
arguments, let's turn back to our limit of jagged
curves that approaches the smooth circular curve.
As I said, the limiting curve really is a circle
and the limiting value for the length of your
approximations really is eight. Here the basic
issue is that there is no reason to expect that
the limit of the lengths of the curves is the same
as the length of the limits of the curves. And,
in fact, this is a nice counter example to show
why that's not the case. The real point of this
example is not the fear that anyone is ever going
to believe that it shows that π is equal to 4.
Instead, it shows why care is required in other
cases where people apply limiting arguments.
For example, this happens all throughout calculus,
it is the heart of calculus. Where, say you want
to know the area under a given curve, the way we
typically think about it is to approximate that
with a set of rectangles, because those are
the things we know how to compute the areas of,
you just take the base times height in each
case. Now this is a very jagged approximation,
but the thought or the hope is that as you
take a finer and finer subdivision into thinner
and thinner rectangles the sums of those areas
approaches the thing we actually care about.
If you want to make it rigorous you have
to be explicit about the error between
these approximations and the true thing we care
about, the area under this curve. For example,
you might start your argument by saying that that
error has to be strictly less than the area of
these red rectangles. Essentially, the deviation
between the curve and our approximating rectangles
sits strictly inside that red region. And then,
what you would want to argue, is that in this
limiting process the cumulative area of all of
those red rectangles has to approach zero.
Now as to the final example: our proof
that all triangles are isosceles.
Let me show you what it looks like if I'm
a little bit more careful about actually
constructing the angle bisector
rather than just eyeballing it.
When I do that the relevant intersection
point actually sits outside of the triangle.
And then from there, if I go through everything
that we did in the original argument drawing the
relevant perpendicular lines, all of that. Every
triangle that I claimed was congruent really is
congruent. All of those were genuinely true and
the corresponding lengths of those triangles that
I claimed were the same really are the same.
The one place where the proof breaks down
is at the very end when I said that the full
side length AC was equal to AE plus EC. That
was only true under the hidden assumption that
that point E sat in between them, but in reality,
for many triangles that point would sit outside
of those two. It's pretty subtle isn't it?
The point in all of this is that while visual
intuition is great and visual proofs often give
you a nice way of elucidating what's
going on with otherwise opaque rigor.
Visual arguments and snazzy diagrams will
never obviate the need for critical thinking.
In math you cannot escape the need to look
out for hidden assumptions and edge cases.